what's up guys I'm KJ I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I'm gonna be cuddling some
puppies while I answer some fan
questions and I can't wait give me the
pups let's go
[Music]
okay I was got that from being on a
trampoline I was four years old and I
cracked my head open on the side of the
trampoline and I almost died near-death
experience girlfriend and burger those
are the hottest ones these are my kids
they're like my kids
some of my favorite actors I really
enjoy Ricky Gervais I think he's really
funny
I really like well I like Vince Vaughn I
like funny guys I like watching funny
actors music van Halen Led Zeppelin I
love everything I love I love all kinds
of music
definitely never gonna dye it again yeah
I get it died every two weeks and it's
like the roots so I have to get all the
roots and stuff down every two weeks and
yeah I really hope that I don't go bald
when I'm 30 probably not I probably
would have been friends with jug I don't
know if I would have been friends with
with achi I think we would have been
rivals maybe we would have been both on
the football team we would have had a
similar relationship to Archie and
Reggie you know anything like their
relationship pick one just pick one and
see if it works out before you try
everyone in the whole school interesting
question actually because season five we
kind of unsure on what we're gonna be
doing but I think it would be cool if I
was in the Army or something and I came
back and I wasn't like you know and I
did I didn't go to college and I went
like into the army or something that
would be cool we could shoot me like ah
geez like in the war you know I want
Archie to be single focus on him for a
second instead of why does he always
have to be with someone maybe he can
just show her just focus on himself
maybe you should get a dog maybe you
should get a little puppy
I think the idea of arching Biddy is
really cool just because it's so iconic
and I think the whole end game like ah
Qing baby being in-game is something
really cool I think the fans would
really love that you know just getting
climbed all over you with saying what I
just said I would probably say buggy I
really like buggy I think fans love
buggy buggy no I think right now it's
it's exactly where it needs to be I wish
I was a dog just no worries in the world
look at you looks like a chipmunk
no we don't have any onset rituals we
just kind of hang out before we go on to
it and it's honestly it's not that often
we get all get to work with each other
when we're all in the same scene it's
kind of a it's really fun but it's it's
not often where that happens take :
Charles yeah
at this point no I haven't heard
anything about that that would be really
cool though I'd love to go to New York
and shoot with those guys I don't know I
think Colts pretty similar to jacket
just the broody kind of you know he's
intelligent
- he's pretty funny he's got a dark
sense of humor sorry bro I know he would
hate to hear that but that's true we're
all pretty similar to all characters I
think you know and I think in a way
that's why actors get causes because I
bring the energy to the character as
well as you know bringing everything
else that the writing gives but Natalie
Baldwin plays Penelope blossom is a
really incredible active because she
plays the weirdness of that character so
well I think she's probably the most
revered cuz she's a really incredible
[ __ ] real life when I'm not filming I
get into it even more actually exact
more time it's it's harder actually when
I'm not when I'm working just cuz of the
amount of time that we have to shoot and
stuff oh I work out with a guy called
Alex fine me and Charles Charles
introduced me to him when I work out
them I stay with him usually over a
weekend and he kind of gets me into the
rhythm so that I can go back to
Vancouver and keep everything up again
it's hard and you got to cycle it you
got to you know that you have three
weeks on where you're working out really
hard and then you gotta take a week off
because you can't sustain working that
much in it and then working out on top
of that - you know these puppies were
provided by Vander poms dogs if you want
more information you can visit
Vanderpump dogs doddle
[Music]